yesterday at 5:13 p.m. a Coast Guard
command center was notified of a diving
accident near alligator reef off the
coast of Florida that's where Rob
Stewart had been doing a routine dive
with two friends while shooting the
sequel to shark water called shark water
extinction today Rick speaks with Rob's
sister Alexandra can you tell us what's
going through your mind right now how
are you coping
yeah it's honestly just absolutely
horrifying I can't imagine anything
worse and the only way that we are not
completely breaking down is by
aggressively not thinking about the
outcome she's in Toronto while her
parents have flown down to Florida to
search for their son it doesn't look
great but we got a person that looks
fine so super deep dive in which is 230
feet and they were doing rebreathers for
it two of them went back down this is
the end I get the anchor not the coral
both came back up and the other diver
collapsed on the deck Rob gave an okay
sign when he got to the surface and then
they turned around and he was gone
they've been searching for Emerson Rick
also spoke to Rob's friend and publicist
Tyler McLeod who speculates that Rob may
have forgot to inflate his BC or his
buoyancy compensator it's a piece of
equipment that stopped scuba divers from
sinking protocol is to inflate your BP
when you get to the surface but he was
working on a new system of the
rebreather system and going very deep he
might have be lightheaded she might have
been not fully you know aware so we're
concerned that he we're hoping that he
inflated his BP that works so they're
keeping about the surface the Coast
Guard has been initiated as a defense
this is not something that rather than
thousands of guys
and know of all over the world it was
probably simple of course the equipment
this is the best state-of-the-art
equipment so something went terribly
wrong the search teams using helicopters
planes boats and divers to try and find
Rob well a GoFundMe page is up to
support the growing search efforts we're
so grateful people have been stepping up
big time all over the world to try and
donate and just get us access to more
resources to try and broaden the search
effort the great news we've just gotten
is that the US Coast Guard who has
extended their involvement in the search
at least until tomorrow
Robin Ives and best buddies we were 13
we met in Toronto at school we were best
friends we talked about diving we talked
about being under the water we talked
about saving the ocean I read are doing
up a dive with him many years ago here
with et Canada and gosh I was so
frightened just to do a little dive he
made me feel so comfortable he was I
think more at home in the water that he
yeah that is on land so absolutely if
anybody has a shot at this on the planet
it would be Rob he knows that keep it
you know collecting these we found
people were parade